life is what you make of it your Delta  pack of cars your DNA is fixed by your  mother and your father and you maybe  siblings will you even get different  parts of parcels of the DNA your job is  to make the best of the cars have been  handed out to you what can you do what  can you not do what are you were sad and  you asked me to make my living a self  artists our staff because I just can't  draw it wasn't and my father or my  mother my great grandfathers and  grandmothers but if you ask me to do  mathematical question  also argue points out are dead by now  that's the cards I was handed off and I  make you saw them don't try and do  something you were not favored by nature  to do